un appartement feu dans le quartier du
sanitas à tours cela s'est produit ce
matin le feu est parti d'un tas de linge
installé dans une des chambres de
l'appartement
pour l'heure on ne connaît pas
précisément l'origine de cet incendie
heureusement aucun blessé n'est à
déplorer une personne a été relogés par
le bailleur 18 pompiers se sont rendus
sur place on écoute d'ailleurs le
lieutenant cyril venu hier au micro de
romo des dix au départ par pour un
dégagement de fumée donc qui s'avérait
être un feu dans un appartement d'une
quarantaine de mètres carrés
le feu était localisé dans une pièce un
appartement à bien a bien chauffé il est
complètement inoccupable et nos curés du
relogement à prévoir pour cet
appartement